This is just so funny. I told you in our discussion
of the bogus summary of the Trump phone call
with the Ukrainian president that if the white
house thinks that the summary is not incriminating,
just imagine how bad the full transcript would
be if it were released. There is a new report
out now that onald Trump was incredulous and
shocked earlier this week that when he sent
a transcript of the phone call to Nancy Pelosi,
she didn't read it and immediately call off
the impeachment inquiry. This is how out of
touch the guy is. How disconnected from reality
do you have to be to send something to Nancy
Pelosi that confirms everything that has been
reported is true, or at least it certainly
doesn't disabuse anyone of that belief, and
then you're shocked that Nancy Pelosi didn't
read it and say, you know what? Now that I've
seen what Donald's sent over, I'm going to
cancel the entire impeachment inquiry.
It's also interesting that there are reports
from close to Trump that even though he believes
impeachment might help him politically in
wenty twenty he still doesn't want to be impeached,
and we'll talk more about that when things
settle down a little bit around the whistleblower
report, but the real amazing thing here is
the degree to which onald Trump believes that
he is endlessly convincing. Think back, this
is a personality trait that made Trump say
a year ago or whenever. Sure. I'll sit down
with obert Mueller. That's no problem. I'll
go talk to him in person. Trump believes that
he is so convincing that he is so charismatic
that he is so articulate and a quick thinker
on his feet that people can't tell that he's
lying, that he can just get in a room with
whoever and he can say something or he can
show something in this case a transcript to
Nancy Pelosi and that they will be immediately
overwhelmed by what he is saying or showing
them and they will come over to his point
of view.
And thus he was stunned according to this
report that Nancy Pelosi didn't immediately
cancel the impeachment inquiry because of
what onald Trump sent her. Just another little
a a notch in our understanding of how onald
Trump operates and it certainly is consistent
with everything that we've seen so far.